Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for being part of my world and for listening to this episode, episode number 48, which is just wonderful. We are fast approaching a whole year together, which is ace. I sound a bit different today in my head, in my ears, in my throat, because I haven't been very well. I've got tonsillitis, my tongue feels too thick. I don't feel I can get my words out quite right but people assure me I sound the same but for me all feels different, it all feels different and this has inspired the topic of today's episode of the podcast which will have some possible catchier title of working when we're poorly
我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，并收听第48期节目，这真是太棒了。我们很快就要一起走过整整一年了，这太赞了。今天我的声音听起来有点不同，在我脑海里、耳朵里、喉咙里，因为我病了。我得了扁桃体炎，舌头感觉肿胀。我觉得自己无法准确表达，但人们向我保证听起来没区别，但对我来说，一切都感觉不同。这激发了今天播客的主题，标题可能叫“当我们生病时如何工作”，
as aspiring psychologists and mental health professionals something along those lines yeah I could do is help coming up with catchy podcast titles and with that in mind if you've got any ideas for things you'd like me to talk about on the podcast please let me know honestly please don't be shy otherwise you just get the random stuff that's going on in my life and maybe you enjoy that but I would also like some bottom-up guidance as they say in the research world as well as top down um oh now i'm like oh they think i'm saying i'm the top of the tree i'm not it's just that's you know i'm creating it so that would be top down um so yes please don't be shy head along to my website um www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and let me know what podcast episodes would really
作为有抱负的心理学家和心理健康专业人士，大概就是这类话题。是的，我可以帮忙想一些吸引人的播客标题。考虑到这一点，如果你有任何想让我谈论的话题，请告诉我，真的，请不要害羞。否则你只能听到我生活中随机发生的事情，也许你喜欢那样，但我也会想要一些研究领域所说的“自下而上”的指导，以及“自上而下”的……哦，现在我在想，他们会以为我自认为是顶层人物，我不是，这只是因为我在创作它，所以那是“自上而下”。所以，是的，请不要害羞，前往我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast，告诉我哪些播客剧集会真正
light your fire. Okay, so I recall the first time that it cropped up for me as an issue when I was unwell because it directly impacted on the care of my clients and that's when I was working for a university at undergraduate level. I was doing a job in my second and third year supporting disabled students to optimally engage in their studies so it you it went usually meant going along to to lectures and or exams with them if they had some kind of disability and it could be a kind of long-standing disability or it could have been a temporary disability as well so somebody once broke their right arm and they were right-handed and so I really have awful handwriting I was a very bad person for that job but it was my job to scribe for them so yeah if you're at university and you are experiencing some kind of
点燃你的热情。好的，我记得第一次遇到这个问题是在我生病的时候，因为它直接影响了我对客户的护理，那时我正在一所大学的本科阶段工作。我在大二和大三时做了一份工作，支持残疾学生以最佳方式参与学习。这通常意味着如果他们有某种残疾，我就要陪他们去上课或参加考试。这可能是一种长期残疾，也可能是临时残疾。比如有人曾摔断了右手，而他是右撇子，我的字迹真的很糟糕，我不适合那份工作，但我的职责是为他们代写。所以，是的，如果你在大学里，并且正在经历某种
difficulty with accessing the level platform to engage in your studies please remember that there are student support services there and there will be likely some service to support you to you know to more to more optimally engage that it's that it's fairer for you and that might be like I said a long-standing difficulty that you've got such as what we discussed with with Dr Deborah Kingston when we're speaking about ADHD and we're thinking about the centre for academic writing but also you know if you've got any kind of additional needs or mobility issues, then you can contact your student support centre and see in what way they might be able to help you. And then you might get someone, hopefully someone with slightly neater writing than me, runs in the family. My brother has got such awful writing that the university had to pay to have his work
获取学习平台的困难，请记住那里有学生支持服务，很可能会有服务来支持你，让你能更优化地参与学习，这对你来说更公平。正如我所说，这可能是一种长期困难，比如我们与Deborah Kingston博士讨论ADHD和学术写作中心时提到的那样。但如果你有任何额外的需求或行动不便，也可以联系你的学生支持中心，看看他们能如何帮助你。然后你可能会得到某个人，希望是一个字迹比我稍微整洁一点的人，这在家族里是有遗传的。我哥哥的字迹太糟糕了，大学不得不花钱请人把他的作业
transcribed so that they could score it and he was doing pure maths that's not easy stuff to transcribe when I used to look at his work I couldn't even read it so we've got very different brains I'm into language and emotions not at all arty I don't think either of us are actually he was used to be quite good at art he used to be quite good at painting pictures of my rabbits um and the cats and things he often used to do that for his art homework so I think he is artier than me um so yeah he got the arty brain um and the maths logic brain um and yeah I got got the other stuff. I got the other stuff. I don't know who's doing better, but we're both doing all right. So there we go. Another aside into my life, which I know some of you enjoy. So as I was saying, the first time this cropped up for me
转录出来以便评分，他学的是纯数学，那可不是容易转录的内容。我以前看他的作业时甚至读不懂，所以我们的大脑非常不同。我擅长语言和情感，一点也不艺术。我不认为我们俩中任何一个是艺术天才，其实他以前很擅长艺术，他以前很擅长画我的兔子、猫之类的东西，他经常在美术作业里这样做，所以我认为他比我更有艺术细胞。所以，是的，他继承了艺术大脑和数学逻辑大脑，而我……我得到了其他东西。我不知道谁做得更好，但我们都做得不错。所以，这就是我的生活插曲，我知道你们中有些人喜欢这些。所以正如我所说，第一次出现这个问题
as an issue was when I was in undergraduate study. And when I was then ill, I thought, oh, no, but it means so and so will have some sort of disruption to their lecture. You know, they'll be unsettled. So I was working with some people that had autism as well. And sometimes I just like to know that there was someone nearby in case anything went wrong that they could get to help to problem solve um so yeah you if you are in this role yourself or looking to to apply to this role you'll be working with a variety of different presentations so there's that sense that you know am i am i ill enough to warrant wrecking two people's days you know so um i don't know about you, and I'm not advocating this, but certainly when it came to studying for final exams for myself, my lecture notes were
是在我读本科的时候。当我生病时，我想，哦不，这意味着某某人的课程会受到干扰。你知道，他们会感到不安。我当时也在和一些患有自闭症的人一起工作。有时他们只是想知道附近有人，以防万一出了什么问题，他们可以寻求帮助来解决问题。所以，是的，如果你自己担任这个角色，或者打算申请这个角色，你将与各种不同表现的人一起工作。所以会有那种感觉，你知道，我病得够重到足以毁掉两个人的日子吗？所以……我不知道你们怎么样，我并不提倡这样做，但肯定在我自己准备期末考试时，我的课堂笔记
usually in an assortment of mine and three of my closest friends writing, so usually one of us of the four of us would have been to the lecture um and yeah I'm going to name check them here because they're so lovely Claire Gemma and Katie um usually between us I'm sure they were dreading the day that it was my notes they had to read but between us when we'd attended lectures or seminars um and the other person hadn't we'd pass on our notes um so yeah I did did my bit as well I would say on balance I went to most lectures and probably all seminars because I think the seminars were compulsory and the lectures at that time were not um but yeah um not all of my not all of my original notes were in my own handwriting um so yeah it was quite interesting to see how just how many of those
通常是我和我三个最亲密朋友的字迹混合在一起。所以通常我们四个人中会有一个人去上课。是的，我要在这里点名表扬她们，因为她们太可爱了：Claire、Gemma和Katie。通常我们之间……我相信她们一定很害怕读到我笔记的那一天，但当我们参加讲座或研讨会，而另一个人没去时，我们会互相传阅笔记。所以，是的，我也尽了我的本分。我会说总的来说，我参加了大部分讲座，可能所有的研讨会，因为我认为研讨会是强制性的，而当时的讲座不是。但是的，并非我所有的原始笔记都是我自己的笔迹。
there were um that I then had to kind of read and understand and um get into some ship shape order for my own exams and coursework so yeah if it's probably all different now you probably will take laptops or um you know iPads and stuff but at at the time, that was incredibly rare. So I started university in 1999. It was incredibly rare to have anybody tip tapping away. It might have been sort of one person at the front. And that was it. But I'm sure it's very different now. And even when I went to to do some teaching at a declensi course, they were all sat there with their laptops tip-tapping what I said and it was a very different experience whereas when I did teaching we'd all sit in um a sort of a ring shape um you know with the presenter standing at the open end of the ring um the open
所以，看到有多少笔记是我不得不阅读、理解并整理成适合我考试和课程作业的样子，这很有趣。所以，是的，现在可能完全不同了，你们可能会用笔记本电脑或iPad之类的东西，但在当时，这极其罕见。我是1999年开始上大学的。当时有人在敲敲打打是非常罕见的。可能只有前排的一个人。就是这样。但我相信现在非常不同了。甚至当我去做一些临床心理学课程的教学时，他们都坐在那里用笔记本电脑敲打我所说的话，那是一种非常不同的体验。而当我教学时，我们都会坐成一个圆圈，
end of the circle um and it was very collaborative. And, you know, you could get instant sort of eye connection with people to get a sense that you were being understood. Whereas talking to the back of sort of 15 laptops isn't quite the same, you know, and it, it puts that distance between you and the, you know, the people that you're speaking to um which I didn't necessarily enjoy actually um I really thought there was something very special about being in the room with 15 people you know with nothing on their laps just bringing themselves um with nothing getting in the way that was something quite unique so um yeah if you are going on to training i would suggest sometimes that you just maybe suggest just being you know
演讲者站在圆圈的开口处，这非常有协作性。而且，你可以获得即时的眼神交流，感觉到你被理解了。而对着15台笔记本电脑的背面说话就不一样了，你知道，这在你和你说话的人之间拉开了距离，我其实并不一定喜欢那样。我真的认为和15个人待在一个房间里，膝盖上什么都没有，只是带着自己，没有任何东西阻碍，这非常特别。所以，是的，如果你要进行培训，我有时会建议，也许可以提议大家只用纸笔做笔记，
how about we take pen and paper notes um or one of us takes pen and paper notes, we take turns to scribe, so that the rest of you can take turns in really immersing yourself in the process. This is a total aside, this is nothing to do with being poorly. But, you know, just talking about technology, and how that, how that crops up at universities. But, yes, so what I was saying was that it was if I was going to be sick I had to kind of work out whether I was sick enough to not go and obviously if you had a vomit bug or something then you really can't go you know the basic infection control principles are usually that you're not welcome back between 48 and 72 hours after you've last been sick um and so you know your hands are tied in that regard um and so you know you can't go um certainly in the NHS it's it's 48 hours
或者我们轮流做笔记，这样其他人就可以轮流真正沉浸在过程中。这完全是题外话，与生病无关。但是，你知道，只是谈论技术，以及它如何在大学里出现。但是，是的，我刚才说的是，如果我要生病，我必须弄清楚我是否病得重到不能去。显然，如果你有呕吐病之类的，那你真的不能去。你知道，基本的感染控制原则通常是你最后一次呕吐后48到72小时内不欢迎你回来。所以，你知道，你在那方面束手无策，所以你不能去。当然在NHS，是最后一次呕吐后48小时，
after you've last been sick it might have been 72 I can't quite recall um but in those positions you're going to have to not support your service user, which means you're going to need to phone in sick. And it's never an easy thing to do, you know, having to make that phone call to your supervisor, your manager or team lead or, you know, duty receptionist and say, I'm sorry, I'm not coming in. And, you know, we can soften the blow these days by sending an early text to somebody and then saying, well, I'll call in when the lines are open at nine. But it's not easy. And so this cropped up for me this week because I've had tonsillitis. I've been really unwell. You know, I first started feeling dodgy Friday, which was the day we got back from holiday I felt dizzy just completely exhausted but like excessively exhausted um because actually you know I hadn't had late nights I hadn't had you know there was no reason I should be feeling that exhausted after a holiday you know we'd done lots of walking
可能是72小时，我记不太清了。但在这些职位上，你将不得不停止支持你的服务对象，这意味着你需要请病假。这从来都不是一件容易的事，你知道，必须给你的主管、经理或团队负责人，或者值班接待员打电话说，对不起，我今天不去上班了。而且，你知道，我们现在可以通过给某人发早安短信来缓解这种尴尬，然后说，好吧，等九点线路开放时我会打电话。但这并不容易。所以这周我遇到了这个问题，因为我得了扁桃体炎。我病得很重。你知道，我周五开始感觉不对劲，那是我们度假回来的那天。我感到头晕，完全精疲力竭，但那种精疲力竭是过度的，
but I should usually I would feel uplifted and invigorated by that rather than completely drained and the bed wasn't as comfortable as I would have wanted it to be but it was not enough to warrant being that exhausted so yeah it's been rumbling and then from Sunday I just didn't feel well at all um and yeah then my tonsils were just awful awful awful awful to the extent that the doctor took pity on me on Monday and prescribed me some antibiotics so thank you to her she was lovely um and then I started to turn a corner so I'm doing this on Wednesday afternoon and I started to turn a corner Tuesday evening I would say I started to oh oh I feel a bit more like myself but um I have been not role modeling terrifically well because
因为实际上，你知道，我没有熬夜，没有理由在度假后感到那么疲惫。你知道，我们走了很多路，但通常我应该会感到振奋和充满活力，而不是完全被抽干。床也没有我想象的那么舒服，但不足以导致那么疲惫。所以，是的，这种感觉一直在持续，从周日开始我就感觉一点也不好。然后我的扁桃体真的太糟糕了，糟糕到周一医生对我产生了怜悯，给我开了些抗生素。所以感谢她，她很可爱。然后我开始好转，我是在周三下午录制这个节目的，我想说周二晚上我开始好转了，我感觉更像我自己了。但是，我并没有做出很好的榜样，因为
um on the Monday when I was feeling dreadful I didn't want to let my um membership down so I still did my usual lunchtime live which is if you if you're familiar with the compassionate Q&A it's like that but people ask me any questions once a week so if you like the compassionate Q&A it's like that but people ask me any questions once a week so if you like the compassionate Q&As and you would like more of them then you can get those within my membership so that's worth bearing in mind as well but then that evening I also had the second and final compassionate Q&A of this application stage and because I'd been advertising it on the podcast and on socials I didn't want to let people down and because I knew that it is application season and the applications in case you're not aware for DeclinSci certainly for for clearinghouse they're due in before 1 p.m on the 16th of
周一我感觉糟糕透顶时，我不想让我的会员失望，所以我还是做了通常的午餐直播。如果你熟悉“同情问答”（Compassionate Q&A），就是那样，但人们每周问我任何问题。如果你喜欢“同情问答”，想要更多，你可以在我的会员资格中获得，这也值得考虑。但那天晚上，我还有这个申请阶段的第二次也是最后一次“同情问答”。因为我已经在播客和社交媒体上宣传过了，我不想让人们失望。而且因为我知道现在是申请季，如果你不知道的话，临床心理学课程的申请，特别是对于清算所（Clearinghouse），截止日期是16日下午1点之前。
november in case that's not on your radar it's coming up very soon so my virtual assistant had said to me why don't you just you know postpone it and do it later in the week when you're when you're more well you know and i entertained that idea for a couple of seconds and I just thought no because I want to do I want to do it now and of course it is a bit different because it meant that I was having to work for an hour and a half you know in my own house it's not like I had to get a train, you know, go out in the pouring rain, stand around for a while. It was more compartmentalised. I do think with the commonality that we have of working from home these days, we are more likely to do some work on the days when we should be or indeed we are on sick leave so um yeah I probably if I was being entirely fair to myself I would have got Hannah to contact the clients and to look up their numbers
如果你还没注意到，它很快就要到了。所以我的虚拟助理曾对我说，为什么不推迟到周内你身体好点的时候再做呢？我考虑了几秒钟，但我只是想，不，因为我想现在就做。当然，这有点不同，因为这意味着我必须在自己家里工作一个半小时。这不像我必须去赶火车，在倾盆大雨中出门，站上一会儿。这更易于拆分。我确实认为，随着如今居家办公的普遍性，我们更有可能在应该休病假的日子里做一些工作。所以，是的，如果我对自己完全公平的话，我应该让Hannah联系客户，查出他们的号码并取消，这当然是我们以前在NHS的好日子里所做的。在有笔记本电脑之前，你根本无法访问VPN连接来安全地获取客户的联系方式以进行取消。所以这通常是通过办公室完成的，他们从台式机上查看信息，打电话给病人，告知他们临床医生今天身体不太舒服，等他们康复后再联系。但我确实认为我们更有可能做一些工作，这部分是因为我们不想给别人带来不便，因为当然有时是临床医生必须做这些，然后还要给有时已经超负荷的行政人员打电话，让他们去打那些电话。所以如果我们能做点什么来减轻负担，最小化任何失望或不便，我想我们可能仅仅因为我们职业的本质，更愿意这样做。但请记住，你不必这样做。你知道，如果你病得无法工作，你只需要报告你无法履行职责。考虑到这一点，我认为我感觉最糟糕的一次是在2016年。那时我有一个三个月大的婴儿和一个三岁的孩子。我们正在扩建房子，没有厨房，我还得了支气管炎。那个周末，幼儿园把我儿子送回家，带着班级兔子Wilf，让他在家度过一段美妙的时光。
and cancel which is of course what we used to do in the good old days of the NHS before we had laptops you just you didn't have any access to you know vpn connections to be able to securely access your client's contact details to cancel and so then that would be done via the office you know from their desktops they would look at information call the patient and let them know that unfortunately the clinician isn't very well today and they will make contact when they are well again but i do think we're more likely to do some of it and whether that's partly because we don't want to inconvenience anyone else because of course it's sometimes clinicians that have to do that and then telephone sometimes already
然后取消，这当然是我们过去在国民医疗服务体系（NHS）的美好旧时光里所做的事情，那时我们还没有笔记本电脑，你根本无法访问任何VPN连接来安全地获取客户的联系方式以进行取消，所以这些工作都是通过办公室完成的，你知道，他们会从台式机上查看信息，给病人打电话，告知他们很遗憾临床医生今天身体不太舒服，等他们康复后会再联系。但我确实认为我们更有可能自己做一些这样的工作，这部分原因可能是因为我们不想给别人带来不便，因为当然有时必须由临床医生来做这件事，而且有时电话已经
overstretched admin staff having to make those phone calls and so if we can do something to lessen the load of our you know minimize, minimise any disappointment or inconvenience. I think we are probably, just by the very nature of our profession, we're more likely to want to do that. But do bear in mind that you don't have to. You know, if you're not well enough to work, that you just need to report that you're not well enough for duty. And with that in mind, you know, I think the most unwell I've ever felt was in 2016. And at that point, I had a three-month-old baby and a three-year-old. And we were having an extension. We had no kitchen. And I had bronchitis. And this was the weekend where the preschool had sent my little boy home with Wilf, the class bunny, to have a marvellous time at home.
让过度劳累的行政人员去打那些电话，所以如果我们能做些什么来减轻他们的负担，你知道，尽量减少任何失望或不便。我想我们可能仅仅因为我们职业的本质，更愿意这样做。但请记住，你并不一定要这样做。你知道，如果你身体不适无法工作，你只需要报告你无法履行职责即可。考虑到这一点，你知道，我想我感觉最不舒服的一次是在2016年。那时我有一个三个月大的婴儿和一个三岁的孩子。我们当时正在扩建房子，没有厨房。我还得了支气管炎。而那个周末，幼儿园让我小儿子把班里的兔子威尔夫带回家，让它在家里度过一段美妙的时光。
And my youngest, the baby, didn't sleep um he'd wake me several times a night um he um he was breastfed and so you know when you're unwell and breastfeeding it's not the easiest um although at least you can lay flat in bed you know hopefully the child might go to sleep and then you can put them back in their cot but basically you know I do recall at one stage googling at that time can you die of bronchitis because I felt so awful so awful and then having to somehow entertain this class bunny and pretend we're having a nice time when mummy's too ill to leave the house and the house is in utter chaos because we had no kitchen, the living room had everything in it, my youngest didn't have a bedroom so all his clothes were there, laundry was everywhere, it was an awful awful time and yeah
我最小的孩子，那个婴儿，不睡觉，他每晚会把我吵醒好几次。他是母乳喂养的，所以你知道，当你生病且在哺乳时，这并不容易。虽然至少你可以平躺在床上，你知道，希望孩子能睡着，然后你可以把他们放回婴儿床。但基本上，我确实记得有一次在那段时间谷歌搜索“支气管炎会死人吗”，因为我感觉太糟糕了，太糟糕了。然后还得想办法招待这只班级兔子，假装我们过得很愉快，而妈妈病得连门都出不去，家里乱成一团，因为我们没有厨房，客厅里堆满了东西，我最小的孩子没有卧室，所以他所有的衣服都在那里，到处都是脏衣服，那是一段糟糕透顶的时光。是的，
I thankfully you know I came through it but I was really so unwell um I definitely couldn't have gone to work and yet still here I was having to look after two children um but yeah my husband I do recall rallying around he gets a very he gets an awful pained expression on his face when I'm ill he's so used to me just getting on with and doing things and you know sorting the kids breakfasts and because I'm an early bird so I'll often be up anyway so from sorting my own breakfast and drinks and things you know I just do it for the kids as part of the things that I do um and I think when I'm not well enough to do them suddenly it's like oh I don't really like you doing I'm well are you okay do you
谢天谢地，我挺过来了，但我真的病得很重。我绝对不可能去上班，但即便如此，我还是得照顾两个孩子。是的，我确实记得我丈夫在四处奔波，当我生病时，他脸上会露出一种痛苦的表情。他太习惯我只是继续做事情，处理孩子们的早餐，因为我是个早起的人，所以我通常都会起床。所以从整理我自己的早餐和饮料之类的，我只是作为我做的事情的一部分为孩子们做。我想当我病得无法做这些时，突然间就像是“哦，我不喜欢你生病，你还好吗？你需要什么吗？”
need anything um whereas I'm yeah I'm a provider I'm a nurturer I'm used to being one do you want a cup of tea do you want anything you know and I usually probably four or five times a week with cooked tea and then suddenly like I can't do any of that you know I'm laying flat and so it's um yeah it's tricky when we've got different roles and then you're not well enough to do any of them um but yes um so my point with where I was going with that is you know we try and we do like this you know adjusting don't we um where we think well you know I'm I could be more unwell maybe I'm not unwell enough but you know we've got to be compassionate here we've got to
而我，是的，我是提供者，我是养育者，我习惯于成为那个问“你要喝杯茶吗？你需要什么吗？”的人。我通常每周四五次做饭，然后突然间我什么都做不了，我只能平躺着。所以，是的，当我们有不同的角色，而你又病得无法履行任何角色时，这很棘手。但是的，我提到这一点是想说，我们尝试并调整，不是吗？我们想，“嗯，我可能病得更重，也许我病得还不够重”。但你知道，我们必须有同情心，我们必须
think well how much more unwell would you need to be to not go you know or should you be going and you know well if this got worse and you were admitted to hospital then there'd be no question about it you couldn't work from hospital and so you know what we also know is if we give ourselves time to properly rest and recharge. So I spent all of Monday in bed, apart from the one and a half hours I mentioned. And I spent all of Tuesday, every second of Tuesday in bed until about 4 p.m. when I thought I'd try and cook tea to see if I could manage it because I'd started to feel a bit better. So other than that that I was laying flat
想一想，“你需要病到什么程度才不去上班？”或者“你应该去吗？”如果情况恶化，你被送进医院，那就毫无疑问了，你不能在医院工作。所以，我们也知道，如果我们给自己时间好好休息和充电。所以周一我整天都在床上，除了我提到的那一个半小时。周二我整天，每一秒都在床上，直到下午4点左右，我想试着做饭看看能不能应付，因为我开始感觉好一点了。所以除此之外，我都是平躺着。
I've watched some Netflix I've read some book I did check my emails and try to do a bit of my accounting software but that's like non-work doesn't count as work for me because you're just literally locating receipts and attaching them and stuff so yeah you know and also we've got to think when we're employed which i'm not self-employed a sick day when you're self-employed is a painful thing because you're not getting paid um but yeah you've got to think about sometimes when you are employed about your sickness absence and how that's looked upon and that can pressure you into work or pressure you to consider saying can I work from home today because I'm not feeling that well or you know I don't want anybody else to get sick but actually you're probably not really well enough to be there at all you know if you're not well enough to be in a building are you well enough to work full stop um so yeah i'd love your thoughts on this
我看了些Netflix，读了些书。我确实查了邮件，试着做了一点会计软件的工作，但这不算工作，对我来说不算，因为你只是在定位收据并附上它们之类的。所以，是的，我们还得考虑当我们受雇时——我不是自雇人士——自雇时的病假是一件痛苦的事情，因为你拿不到钱。但当你受雇时，你必须考虑你的病假缺勤以及它是如何被看待的，这会迫使你工作，或者迫使你考虑“我今天能在家工作吗？因为我感觉不太好”，或者“我不想让别人也生病”。但实际上，你可能根本没有好到可以工作的程度。你知道，如果你病得无法进入大楼，你还能工作吗？所以，是的，我很想听听你们对此的想法。
um come along and discuss with me but for now we've got a little break and i'll be back along very soon so many tips and lessons to learn from so many things that you can try the aspiring psychologist collective the aspiring psychologist collective hello my name is avalon and i'm an undergraduate psychology student. I really enjoyed reading the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and I really honestly just couldn't put it down. I found it really helpful because as I'm in my final year I'm starting to think about what I'd like to do after uni and up until this point I've been very set on the idea of pursuing an AP role and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective helped me to see that there are so many more options out there that may appeal to me and I'm looking forward to exploring some of these and broadening out my options. And I also really appreciated that
来和我讨论吧，但现在我们要休息一下，我很快就会回来。有这么多技巧和经验教训，有这么多你可以尝试的事情。《有抱负的心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）。你好，我叫Avalon，是一名心理学本科生。我真的很喜欢读《有抱负的心理学家集体》，老实说，我真的爱不释手。我觉得它非常有帮助，因为我正处于最后一年，开始思考毕业后想做什么。到目前为止，我一直非常坚定地想要追求助理心理学家（AP）的角色，而《有抱负的心理学家集体》帮助我看到还有更多选择可能吸引我，我很期待探索其中一些并拓宽我的选择。我也非常感谢
people were open about their lived experience and how they navigated this over their psychology journey. I had lived experience of an eating disorder, so it was really inspiring to hear about how people have brought that into their reflections and how it shaped the clinicians that they are today. Thank you so much for that testimonial. I would love your testimonials of the podcast, of the books, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, the Grief Collective, the Clinical Psychologist Collective. So please do come along to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And then you can click for how you can very simply leave me an audio testimonial it really is just a couple of clicks so please do look into that and whilst you're there
人们公开了他们的生活经历以及他们如何在心理学旅程中应对这些。我有过饮食失调的生活经历，所以听到人们如何将这些带入他们的反思，以及它如何塑造了他们今天的临床医生形象，真的很鼓舞人心。非常感谢你的推荐。我很乐意收到你们对播客、书籍、《有抱负的心理学家集体》、《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）、《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）的推荐。所以请前往我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast。然后你可以点击了解如何非常简单地给我留下音频推荐，真的只需要点击几下，所以请务必看看。当你还在那里的时候，
just pick up your phone scroll to the apple podcasts app and then rate us and review us if you have a couple more moments that That would be so gratefully received. So we're thinking about ill health today. And of course, there can be a number of causes of ill health. So, so far, we've spoken about transient conditions such as bronchitis and colds and tonsillitis. And if you're battling any of those currently, I feel for you. I used to have tonsillitis all the time when I was an aspiring psychologist and I'd forgotten just how awful it is. So if you have that right now, if you've got a really horrid cold and you just want your bed um you just want a cuddle um please know that I'm sending you my solidarity came to 1am um the other morning and I felt so wretched
拿起你的手机，滚动到Apple Podcasts应用程序，给我们评分和评论。如果你还有几分钟时间，那将不胜感激。所以我们今天在思考疾病。当然，疾病的原因有很多。到目前为止，我们谈论了支气管炎、感冒和扁桃体炎等短暂性疾病。如果你目前正在与其中任何一种作斗争，我为你感到难过。我以前做有抱负的心理学家时经常得扁桃体炎，我忘记了它有多糟糕。所以如果你现在有这种情况，如果你得了非常严重的感冒，只想躺在床上，只想被拥抱，请知道我向你表示慰问。前几天早上到了凌晨1点，我感觉太痛苦了，
wretched is the word and my husband was asleep and I wanted to wake him up and say I don't feel I just feel so awful um but I thought I probably wouldn't be fair so I didn't and then when he eventually woke up he said oh you were awful last night you were just awful awful to share a bed I was like I know I felt so unwell but yeah to my mind he was asleep all of the time but clearly he wasn't he was probably awake when I was asleep and making a lot of noise and being just very unwell. So if you're not feeling well, yeah, feel better soon. Try and look after yourself. Try to eat if you can stomach it. Try to keep your hydration up. See if you can ask other people to help you. Something we're not that good at all the time you know can
“痛苦”这个词很贴切。我丈夫在睡觉，我想把他叫醒说“我感觉太糟糕了”，但我认为这可能不公平，所以我没这样做。后来他醒来时说：“哦，你昨晚太糟糕了，分享一张床太糟糕了。”我说：“我知道，我感觉太不舒服了。”但对我来说，他一直在睡觉，但显然他没有。他可能在我睡觉时醒着，而我发出了很大的声音，病得很重。所以如果你感觉不舒服，是的，祝你早日康复。试着照顾好自己。如果能吃得下，试着吃点东西。试着保持水分。看看能不能请别人帮你。这是我们有时不太擅长的事情，你知道，
you ask someone to look after you or to look after the people you would usually look after they might be small people they might be grown-up people they might be your siblings can you ask for more help so that you can focus on just some ah and ah and maybe even a nap you know I had a nap the other day Monday afternoon I thought oh because I'm yeah I'm working I can work from bed I really couldn't I just wasn't well enough so I had a nap and then thankfully felt a little bit better to be able to do my compassionate Q&A but the next day my friend contacted me and she's like Marianne you look so unwell you look so unwell when you were doing that you sure you should have been doing that I was like I didn't want to let people down
你能请人照顾你，或者照顾你通常照顾的人吗？他们可能是小孩，可能是成年人，可能是你的兄弟姐妹。你能寻求更多帮助吗？这样你就可以专注于休息，甚至小睡一会儿。你知道，前几天周一下午我小睡了一会儿，我想“因为我在工作，我可以在床上工作”，我真的做不到，我病得太重了。所以我小睡了一会儿，谢天谢地感觉好了一点，能够进行我的“同情问答”。但第二天我朋友联系我，她说：“Marianne，你看起来太不舒服了，你做那个的时候看起来太不舒服了，你确定你应该做那个吗？”我说：“我不想让人们失望。”
um so yes um if you are going through a sticky patch right now please look after yourselves um and I hope it passes soon but of course transient ill health is not always the reason for sickness absence you know perhaps you live with chronic pain or you've got a physical health condition you know maybe even you've got asthma or allergies that mean that you can't always get into work and that obviously is impacted upon by any sickness absent policies as well you know because HR can get a bit twitchy in occupational health when you start having more days over a certain allocation in a time period it's not easy stuff and you know it does affect our decision of thinking about whether we are well enough to be at work or whether we're unwell enough to be at home and not working so this is not easy stuff but you can always talk to your
所以，是的，如果你现在正经历一段艰难时期，请照顾好自己，我希望它很快过去。但当然，短暂的疾病并不总是病假缺勤的原因。你知道，也许你患有慢性疼痛，或者你有身体健康状况，你知道，也许你甚至有哮喘或过敏，这意味着你不能总是去上班。这显然也会受到任何病假缺勤政策的影响，因为当你开始在一段时间内超过一定配额的天数时，人力资源部门和职业健康部门会变得有点紧张。这并不容易，你知道，它确实影响了我们关于“我是否病得足以去上班”或“我是否病得足以在家不工作”的决定。所以这并不容易，但你总是可以和你的
supervisor you can always talk to occupational health if you want to to think about um any changes to your working practices that might make it easier for you to work um you know and certainly occupational health are responsible for things like display equipment and the comfort of your chair. So if you've got any back problems, it's really important that you have a properly fitted, you know, desk, chair, workplace assessment. And sometimes they will leave that with your sticker on the back of the chair, making sure that no one else touches it because it's set up for you. adjustment and sometimes they will leave that with your sticker on the back of the chair making
主管谈谈，如果你想的话，也可以和职业健康部门谈谈，考虑一下对你的工作方式进行任何改变，这可能会让你更容易工作。你知道，当然，职业健康部门负责显示设备和椅子舒适度之类的事情。所以如果你有任何背部问题，拥有一个经过适当调整的办公桌、椅子和工作场所评估非常重要。有时他们会把贴纸贴在椅子背面，确保没有其他人碰它，因为它为你设置好了。
sure that no one else touches it because it's set up for you so yeah don't struggle on in physical pain make sure that work are looking after you getting you any wrist guards or anything that you might need to you know to protect your wrists and things like that so yeah contact your occupational health if you think there are adjustments that could be made to make your life self to give your full attention to what your clients are saying and to be sitting with their distress if you're feeling you know in pain or really unwell the answer is usually no and so in doing yourself a service of staying home and not working you're also likely doing your clients a service because then when they do see you again you're firing on all cylinders and you know therapy might then move more quickly as well and whatever you're doing feel less of a struggle
所以，是的，不要在身体疼痛中挣扎，确保工作单位在照顾你，为你提供你可能需要的任何护腕或任何东西，以保护你的手腕之类的。所以，是的，如果你认为可以做出调整来让你的生活……为了全神贯注于客户所说的话，并与他们的痛苦共处，如果你感到疼痛或病得很重，答案通常是否定的。所以，通过待在家里不工作，你可能也为你的客户做了贡献，因为当他们再次见到你时，你状态饱满，你知道，治疗可能会进展得更快，无论你在做什么，感觉都不会那么挣扎，
because you actually want to be there which is very different than when you're feeling like you're turning up because you have to be there. And of course, there's other types of sickness as well. This could be mental ill health or it could be complications and just normal run of the mill pregnancy can make you quite unwell as well. But also if people are trying to conceive with assisted fertilization that can be quite disruptive to your health and to the way that you feel. I was once doing a session with a young person in CAMHS when I was pregnant and I think it's probably before I told certainly my clients I was pregnant and I remember being sick in my mouth during a session, and having to swallow it down was not nice. So I wasn't sick sick, and I wasn't contagious sick,
因为你实际上想在那里，这与你因为不得不去而感觉像是去应付完全不同。当然，还有其他类型的疾病。这可能是心理健康问题，或者可能是并发症，正常的怀孕也会让你很不舒服。但如果人们正在尝试通过辅助受精受孕，那也会对你的健康和你的感觉产生很大的干扰。我怀孕时曾和CAMHS的一位年轻人进行过一次会谈，我想那可能是在我告诉客户我怀孕之前，我记得在会谈中我嘴里感到恶心，不得不咽下去，那感觉不好。所以我不是那种生病，也不是传染性疾病，
but I wasn't living my best life then. I remember sitting in my office. I did have an office in that service, which was marvellous. It was a shared office, but it was still a lovely office, shared between me and one other person um but yeah I remember sitting with my head on my desk I was feeling so nauseous so um I see if I wasn't being sick I was feeling nauseous and it's very tricky to carry on so again if you're in that position congratulations if you are feeling excited about it. But yeah, awful, awful pregnancy nausea, dreadful. Yeah, I preferred the days I was actually sick, I felt better because, you know, then it's done. But if it's just that awful nausea that seemed to go on all day,
但我当时并没有过上最好的生活。我记得坐在办公室里。我在那个服务部门确实有一个办公室，那太棒了。那是一个共享办公室，但仍然是一个可爱的办公室，我和另一个人共享。但是的，我记得坐在那里，头靠在桌子上，我感到太恶心了。所以，如果我没有呕吐，我也会感到恶心，继续工作非常棘手。所以，如果你处于那个位置，恭喜你，如果你对此感到兴奋的话。但是，是的，糟糕的孕吐，太可怕了。是的，我更喜欢我真的呕吐的日子，我感觉更好，因为那样就结束了。但如果只是那种似乎整天持续的恶心，
there's nothing you can do. Nothing, nothing takes the edge off so um yeah i've been there it passes you know once you have the baby um but yeah luckily both of my nauseous periods seem to stop um yeah into the into the middle trimester the second trimester um so um you know but of course when you are pregnant if you're expecting you know one or multiple babies there can be complications to your health that means that you need to take some sickness absence as well um so i during my first pregnancy um had to take probably about three ish weeks off i'd say and quite significant blood loss I was experiencing and so I was made to stay home until they were confident that that was stopped and that wasn't
你什么也做不了。没有什么能缓解它。所以，是的，我经历过，它会过去的，你知道，一旦你生了孩子。但谢天谢地，我两次恶心期似乎都在进入中期，即孕中期时停止了。所以，你知道，当然，当你怀孕时，如果你期待一个或多个婴儿，可能会有健康并发症，这意味着你也需要请病假。所以，我在第一次怀孕期间，不得不请了大约三周左右的假，我经历了相当严重的失血，所以我被迫待在家里，直到他们确信出血停止了，并且那对我和婴儿没有风险。现在，当然，孕期疾病在病假记录上不算作普通疾病，所以如果你怀孕了，并且你已经告诉了你的职业健康部门——人们确实鼓励你这样做，告诉你的经理，以便可以做出任何调整，确保你在我们工作的环境中没有风险，婴儿也没有风险。所以这是你的选择，但这可能是你在12周扫描之前会选择做的事情。你知道，这不是在社交媒体上分享，也不是与更广泛的团队分享。但这与有管理责任的人分享，他们有责任确保你在工作中安全。所以，当然是你的选择，但这可能是你想要考虑的事情。所以，是的，孕期
a risk to to me or to baby. Now of course pregnancy sickness is doesn't count as sickness in the same way so if you are pregnant and you've told your occupational health which people do encourage you to do to tell your manager so that any you know accommodations can be made as well to make sure that you're not at risk and baby's not at risk in the settings that we work so it is your choice but it might be something that you would choose to do before your 12 week scan. You know, it is not sharing on socials. It is not sharing with the wider team. But this is sharing with somebody who has a managerial and a responsibility to keep you safe at work. So your choice, of course, but it might be something that you want to consider so yeah pregnancy
疾病不计入你通常的病假记录，因为怀孕被称为受保护的特征。所以，是的，我希望这很有用。因为我知道，我们会有身体不舒服，或者心理上感觉不适合工作的时候。这些都是重要的考虑因素。这些也是你很可能会与客户进行的对话。如果他们在工作，他们会和你谈论工作以及他们感觉如何。有时我会对客户说：“这是我的专业建议，我认为你病得不适合工作。”有时人们会觉得这非常有
sickness doesn't count um towards your usual sickness record because pregnancy is what's called a protected characteristic so um yes i hope this has been useful um because what i know is that we will have days where we feel physically unwell or when we feel mentally not well enough to be at work. And these are important considerations. And they're conversations you might well have with your clients as well. If they're working, they'll be talking to you about, you know, working and how well they feel. And sometimes I'll say to a client, it's my professional advice here, I don't think you're well enough to be at work. And sometimes people can find that really
验证感，你知道，因为它给了你许可，不去工作，不去……你知道，减轻那种负罪感，你知道，或者，“Marianne博士也认为我病得不适合工作。”所以现在我可以放松下来，专注于康复。我父亲去世后，我确实有过这种感觉。他在去世后我请了一些病假。全科医生说：“我认为你目前病得不适合工作。你知道，你所做的工作，你所做的创伤工作水平，以及你在日常工作中经常接触到的悲伤程度，我认为你病得不适合在那里。”那真的非常……
validating, you know, because it gives you permission, then to, to not work and to not, you know, to take the take the pressure off that guilt pedal, you know, or, you know, Dr. Marianne also thinks I'm not well enough to work. So now I can relax, you know, into being unwell and really focus on getting better. And I certainly had that when my dad died. So I was on some sick leave after he died. And the GP said, I don't think you are well enough to be at work at the moment. You know, the job you do with the level of trauma work you do and the level of grief that you're regularly rubbing up against in your day-to-day work life I don't think you're well enough to be there and that was really
这是一种认可，你知道，因为它给了你许可，让你不去工作，让你把脚从那块充满负罪感的踏板上移开，你知道，或者，你知道，玛丽安医生也认为我身体状况不佳，无法工作。所以现在我可以放松下来，去面对生病的状态，真正专注于康复。我父亲去世时我确实有过这种感觉。在他去世后，我休了一段时间病假。全科医生说，我认为你目前身体状况不佳，无法工作。你知道，你所做的工作，你所处理的创伤程度，以及你在日常工作中经常接触到的悲伤程度，我认为你现在的身体状况无法胜任，那真的
like I said really validating to have someone else give you permission to have time off work and of course that came in the form of a sick note didn't it but um yeah if if you feel like you can't give yourself permission to be off work then talk to someone else as well who can help you give permission to yourself to even you know get signed off work um all right so i hope you found that useful. Come along to the Aspiring Psychologist community free group to discuss how you're feeling. And if you're not feeling well, come and tell me about it and I will. Oh, I'm sorry to hear. Look after yourself. So, yeah, I'm going to go to bed and I'm going to do the clinical notes from the client I saw this morning and I'm going to edit this podcast episode so I can manage that my mother-in-law has been amazing has been taking the children to and from school whilst I haven't been feeling very well and she's picking them up
就像我说的，有别人给你批准休假确实是一种肯定，当然，这通常是以病假条的形式出现的，对吧？但嗯，如果你觉得无法给自己批准休假，那就找别人谈谈，他们可以帮你给自己批准休假，甚至帮你开病假条。好了，希望这对你有帮助。欢迎加入“有抱负的心理学家”免费社区，讨论你的感受。如果你感觉不舒服，来告诉我，我会……哦，听到这个我很抱歉。照顾好自己。所以，是的，我要去睡觉了，我要完成今天早上见的那位客户的临床记录，还要编辑这期播客，这样我就能处理好这些事了。我婆婆一直很棒，在我身体不舒服的时候，她一直负责接送孩子们上下学，今天她也会去接他们。
for me today and I'm hoping I will be feeling stronger and more able to resume normal service tomorrow that's the plan anyway so so yeah, I hope you found this helpful, hope you can forgive me looking, you probably actually look any different, but I feel like I don't look quite my usual self, um, and why are we so self-deprecating, I don't know, that's a, that's a whole another episode, um, but yeah, thank you for listening, hope you found it useful, and I'm looking forward to catching up with you very soon take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified
我希望明天我能感觉好些，更有能力恢复正常工作，这就是计划。总之，希望你觉得这期节目有帮助。希望你能原谅我看起来……其实你可能看不出有什么不同，但我感觉自己看起来不太像平时的我。为什么我们总是这么自贬呢？我不知道，那是另一期节目的主题了。总之，谢谢你的收听，希望你觉得有用，期待很快与你再会。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这期播客成为你的指南，助你走上获得资格认证的道路。
it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Durant. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well- wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there, and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend
这是玛丽安·杜兰特博士主持的“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我觉得书里讲述的各种故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。书里提到的通往这一职业的多种途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有所谓的完美路径，这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书。
this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下了。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。